[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the break room Our Daily
Show that keeps you updated on all the
nerdy news you need to know uh live from
our Los Angeles Studio here at new
rockstars Today's Show is brought to you
by Pluto TV which offers hundreds of
free live channels and thousands of free
on-demand movies oh yeah on today's show
two black panthers huh
Marvel ending a six-year drought
a little more scroll searching
with me here to do the digging on on
scroll search 2022 uh Macho Man Brandon
Barrett oh yeah you might be out there
having a good time but we're having a
good time in here because you know what
folks when you're having a great time
the cream always Rises oh no oh
wow We've Got A Real American Hero
Jessica Clemens Hulk Hogan here brother
and this 32 inch neck you can't choke
but I'll choke you
wow
it's like um it's like a normal man's
waist wow uh and then
um Miss Foley's son uh
always baby boy have a nice day you
pieces of trash oh I also live in a
boiler room so I get what it's like to
beat you now and I don't like it at all
and I am Eric Bishop uh couple said
we're just as uh wrestlers mostly from
the late 90s uh today for no other
reason than it sounded like a good time
um but on today's show speaking of
wrestlers uh oh and also we got the
championship belt here
um is that a belt it's a title that's
right uh if we hit 250 bucks in super
chat today these all four of these
wrestling personas will cut a promo on
the chat okay maybe individual members
of the chat maybe recurring themes memes
uh whatever uh but we will do that at
the end of the show we will uh
eviscerate you verbally okay
um which I don't know about you but I
would be dying to see what Tommy mankind
would have would say is Mick Foley from
New Jersey he is
[Laughter]
let's do some headlines let's do some
headlines
okay
I did not know that's where he's from
and I will not for even one more second
impersonate someone that I don't even
believe is real oh my God someone said
bullies from Long Island so maybe you're
saying oh okay yeah goes back on yeah
Long Island's in New York New York State
Tommy's favorite state yeah yeah
um okay apologies Tommy put all that
work into his costume then then tore it
off okay according to a larger Variety
article about Peter Safran and James
Gunn's hiring in DC it appears we may
not be getting the Batman 2 until 2025.
apparently Matt Reeves has yet to finish
the script so they are a little ways out
I mean maybe they're spending a little
bit more time on these HBO Max series
spin-offs and their focus is not on the
film I don't know maybe they're waiting
for uh Pattinson to bulk up we don't get
I get it reefs I got a rogue Theory
script I still gotta finish oh boy the
show shoots tomorrow
um uh oh also uh on in DC news according
to the rap DC's live action Wing has a
new name we've been calling it the DC EU
for years now right the DC extended
Universe welcome back good to be back
um but according to uh David uh
Discovery uh Warner Brothers Discovery
Chief David zazilov referred to the
studios on-screen super powered universe
as the DCU
um bolt bolt wow do you think he had DC
you written on a whiteboard he walks
into the room and he's like ladies and
gentlemen I'm gonna blow your minds he
just crosses out the E well here's the
only problem MCU stands for Marvel
Cinematic Universe because the Marvel
Universe in theory includes comic books
right like DCU well the C in DCU stands
for Detective Comics right like so
shouldn't be DCC you wasn't it first
dceu for extended Universe yeah yes
here's something why so they could just
essentially go back to that but they
don't want it but the app when they had
the separate app with shows and stuff it
was like DC Universe right that was the
name of that app yeah it's going out so
it's kind of like they went back to it
in a way but now they're not referring
to that they're referring to films yeah
anyways here's my guess of what happened
he came in the room he said ladies and
gentlemen I want to introduce you to
someone very special Kevin Connolly AKA
E from Entourage then he stood up and he
slid his throat oh my God
it's the DCU get the E out you might
have heard him get the F5
who's dying tonight Kevin Connolly uh
according to the official secret
Invasion account on tenor what's tenor
it's a gift site thank you
you know what but I like because of the
way I live my life it's always a hard G
that's what I'm talking about because
I'm a hard G okay but uh according to
the official secret Invasion account on
tenor Emilia Clark uh Daenerys Targaryen
is playing a character named Abigail
brand in the show which there boom Oh
that's a clip from
um the Marvel Comics Wiki something like
that I don't know ass out torso Twisted
that's the way we like to miss it that's
how you sell comic books oh my God I
can't imagine standing like that in real
life uh thank you to Phantom for
partnering with us uh on a bunch of
content we use fandom wikis all the time
great for Marvel DC Star Wars uh Game of
Thrones all that but we have our own
fandom Wiki pages
I don't am I not real I'm featured on
there I don't know my name you'll see a
phantom I've worked and I'm standing
like this too
I definitely don't have a fandom uh Wiki
because as the chat as the chat can
agree I have no fans okay
I disagree uh but uh so Abigail brand
who is that in the comics she's a half
alien mutant working with sword so
um we could assume maybe that's the role
that she's gonna be playing maybe she is
either fully scroll partially scroll
what do we think a different I mean it
could be anything right also so one of
her parents banged an alien is that what
we're saying well isn't that what this
uh and correct me if I'm wrong in the
comics didn't the Scrolls like not like
breed but they did mix with a lot of
humans to create and that's out alone
look here so she could have just been an
offspring of that because that's what
was like the long line to miss yeah
someone was hiding as a skrull and the
other person if you if you uh you know
get in a relationship with a person who
you think is a human you maybe you get
married maybe you have children whatever
and then one day it's revealed it'll
walk away
by pulling his shirt
now he's paying the price uh okay
he got thrown off the roof of the steel
cage that's right all right
if if you found out your partner and and
the mother or father of your child was a
scroll how like um how like
mad would you be that's a pretty big
betrayal I would think if you went to
the trouble of getting married and
having kids it's time to fess up that
you're a scroll yeah by the way honey
let's go yeah that should be my date too
not even not day two no no no we've
talked about this we've broke this down
about how like it it it it there's a lot
that comes with it there's a lot that
comes with it you gotta trap them yeah a
little honey pot action okay I get that
um on Twitter we got an official poster
for the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special day we got the first uh trailer
for yesterday boom looks fun it looks
like you know kind of solidifies what
the trailer hints at that this is mostly
a Drax and mantis story yeah I also like
the fact that looks like they get wasted
could you imagine drag's drunk that
seems like he's just gonna break
everything I mean he got drunk in the
first movie right when they went to the
barn oh yeah
he's depressed man's depressed he's down
bad and then yeah I forgot about that
scene he should be doing better now
right he's out yes I think like him
romantic or maybe getting closer closer
and maybe that's why they go to Earth so
they have a alone time maybe go to the
you know the erotic no treasure I was
thinking of it as West Hollywood he sees
his daughter in her
um doesn't have to be both uh or it
could be like why not um we don't know
what how they're rocking it on drax's
home planet
um we're uh in uh other Marvel news we
got confirmation uh Rihanna is uh
releasing a new song for the first time
in six years this was the six year
drought we were referencing earlier it's
going to be in uh wakanda forever we
discussed this before yeah we did hear
that she's gonna have a song in it we
were kind of debating about where it is
but she teased it right on Instagram she
put out a little like you hear a little
bit of it and it has like an r in the
wakanda font oh so there's isn't I was
like this must be new updates because we
we talked I remember that time on the
break room I was like we're only gonna
talk about Creed 3 and Rihanna and I
talked about this again it's like last
week or the week before we heard that
she was gonna have a song uh involved in
it it's probably gonna go to the Super
Bowl well on 10 28 8 22 according to the
Instagram post we might hear this whole
song
no one talked to me for five minutes
yeah there's two songs
that are dropping 10 28 right I don't
know if it's two I can't on Twitter I
said too because I was like no one
talked to me for by five no no the two
is um the number of times we talked
about it on this show I love it that's
not the number of songs
um but uh we're looking forward to that
I mean God that first soundtrack was so
great yeah super high I've got it on LP
whoa you're a liar no I don't know
Brandon owns records I got a record
player even though I was born in 2002 I
know what records are hey folks we're
getting a lot of information about black
panther wakanda forever the premieres
tonight uh here in Hollywood California
not here we're in Winnipeg but in
Hollywood California they're having the
premiere this evening uh and during
tonight's NBA double header we're
supposed to get a special look at Black
Panther wakanda forever we did get like
a new little TV spot today uh oh
someone's sneaking in what's happening
hey how's it going
filling in for time
do you have a mic I have a mic
you're welcome man
going on today oh you look older today
thanks I know you look much younger you
know it's really weird
you get a little bit older you get a
little bit older every day well Brandon
it's my birthday oh my gosh happy
birthday Anna right right I can't
believe the government let you have a
birthday everybody uh uh Happy
birthday's in the gym
how dare that what I really want for my
birthday more than anything I may say
you know wanted to uh leave a little
comment and like on my latest Instagram
post about the Wonder Woman music video
oh okay okay what's what's your time
handle oh goombana please don't fire me
goombana that's my personal one how do
you spell that Urbana please don't fire
me g-o-o-m-b-a-m
-a-n-a Goomba plus Anna oh Wonder Woman
video I was thinking banana
not really Goomba plus Anna it's Google
Plus Anna right boy I'm really getting
real
that's great thanks that's great yes
happy birthday well tonight for your
birthday during the NBA double header of
teams that are playing whose names I
don't know uh we're supposed to get a
special look at Black Panther or kind of
forever but earlier today they already
put out a quick little new spot let's
take a look at that real fast
gonna play a little clip play the clip
what is your spirit should he gave me
this to try
[Music]
you know I like them better our four
mothers gave us because it is precise
elegant and
deadly
oh my God
it will not change under my watch
yes General
I told you not to bring them
this is actually a clip that was on Good
Morning America very recently and this
is very interesting because this is a
segment that was very similar to the
clip they showed at d23 of this like
attack at this what kind of science
facility but this part was not in what
they showed this is a little different
uh you see like a coyote talking to
Anika who's Michael Cole's character
it's a new character for the film uh and
she's using these like new daggers uh
and okay he's pissed because she's like
we use Spears here sounds Spanish how
it's always gonna be and she's like no I
got these daggers look at him she's
showing off she's cutting guns now now
is that chekhovs daggers okay so is
either the Koya gonna be killed with
those dads oh or Anika or something's
gonna happen nothing's gonna happen to
those two but like oh my God Michaela
Cole is so badass in that yeah
okay so what uh kind of adding on to
your question don't we know what her
role is in the movie it's not the door
milage well she plays that Nika she is a
part of the Dora melange but we do think
because of the different armor we've
seen uh and we've seen Nakia and like
that armor as well and we know she was
like Nikia was once during melange but
they went on our front to like her
special forces thing yeah there is this
group called The Midnight Angels which
is like an offshoot of the Dora melange
uh and they're kind of more independent
often their own Comics yeah independent
they're not just like guarding the king
they're sent out on like Special
Operations you know if you have the
Marines they're like the Green Berets
are right uh I might get that all mixed
up and in some comic story lines they
kind of have their own agendas yeah from
the wakandan government yeah right so
you think they could be working against
them well I have a bigger grandiose
Theory uh for this movie that it's not
going to be like Namor versus what kind
of from the jump or like Neymar versus
queen raimonda and shuri I think it's
going to be the side characters that
create problems on name or side you got
like a Tuma and nomura and then on like
what kind of you have like characters
like Anika who might not like what's
going on and be like I'm gonna try and
fix things on my own own and create
other problems thus kind of forcing both
sides to then fight each other yeah or
or work against each other because if
Neymar shows up in like a more peaceful
sense of like I don't want to mess with
you guys the tomb was like no screw
these guys let's flood it and floods the
city without uh Neymar's say so but the
Neymar's like I gotta stick with my
people sorry guys do you uh do you think
Anika's gonna try actually hurting Okoye
when it comes at the end of the day I
love Michaela Cole don't do not get me
wrong but Okoye is gonna beat that ass
and akoye is like obviously Marvel is
committed to akoya being a big player
yeah
uh whereas Anika maybe not as much okay
teamwork
okay we might we might see more of uh
Anna hopefully where I left my mask or
sock let's get into this okay my fear is
we won't see Anna at least
um yeah well again I just throw out
anytime and the fact that they're
highlighting it in in this video you
know check out's gun for people they
don't know is a um a theatrical uh
terminology right like if a gun is
presented in act one of a film or a play
it's got to go off by the end right
somebody's gonna get shot right you
don't you don't present uh a weapon
kinetic energy unless it will be used so
like those weapons will play a pivotal
role at some point it could be I mean
okay
um I'm surprised that actually is the
first time that happened well maybe it's
because the mug is heavier than this
plastic cup
um what if it's uh because oh that's the
fight scene that we see later on I think
between uh Neymar's people will receive
the person that's like all blue like
it's in that fight scene maybe we're
just noting that um
we're noting that weapon for when
they're fighting like on the bridge or
something because I do want to believe
that maybe what we see in akoya and
Anika is the same way we're going to see
with shuri and iron heart well it sure
is messing around with like uh or
someone else is messing around with you
know synthetic vibranium or something
like that so I think those knives are
vibranium and the idea that like
something's changed about it and like if
that technology gets out into the wrong
hands or something like that it is a
good idea that this is a problem that's
going to show its face later just
distracting for the camera get close
hey yo
okay uh we have another clip yeah uh
this
I'm sorry
oh okay so they did put out another
trailer today like a a quick little
trailer uh and one of the most you just
you just host
in that trailer uh is that we see a shot
of two black panther helmets side by
side yeah how can we be sure no I'm just
kidding how can we be sure that that's
not they're not a mirror right there
well some hands reach in and pick up one
of them so we know it's not a mirror
trick we know this isn't Pepper's ghost
okay these are two solid helmets uh that
one one of the helmets uh it does look
like a very similar one to the one that
Sherry is holding uh in kind of that
opening funeral scene we say opening
funeral scene because we assume that
happens in the First Act of the movie uh
but and it's also at the beginning of
the trailers that one it looks kind of
more masculine if you will or that it
would fit a bigger slightly larger
possibly a male's head we do see some
hands reaching in uh and picking up the
other one we can kind of guess those are
Sherry's hands you know the trailers
have certainly lent to the idea that
shuri wears a black panther suit at some
point especially because we see those
shuri Panther cannons uh on the hands of
one of the Black Panther suits but
they're showing two side by side yes
which again checkups gun principle I
will be helmet that is the second of
what will be 12 chekhov's gun references
in this episode right like so that also
means do we see simultaneous two black
panther suits being used at the same
time I think so it's something for a
while right that there will be multiple
people wearing black panther suits so if
we're assuming shuries in one who's in
the other one I mean
imbaku he's the only other major it was
a bigger helmet is it big enough is it
is a lot of man okay
it's possible we'll get uh Tommy is the
uh big head expert he can uh maybe he
can eyeball Winston Duke and guess it
like what size is what's his lips his
Cranium is and how big a black panther
helmet would need to be to to fit that
Tommy what what what what are your
thoughts oh boy now you got glasses
Thomas Cruz coming in now
I've done the research I know
uh show me the clip
oh it's just two giant heads yeah one
that's the that that is the head of one
Winston K Duke Brighton High School
graduate Rochester New York resident you
can't hide from your past in Rochester
much longer we want to give you the key
to the city
can we want to give you the key to the
city come on come on the show Winston
would the other one not be uh Michaela
Cole yeah I mean it could be yeah uh
because embaku doesn't really he doesn't
Vibe with the whole black panther stuff
right unless he doesn't follow bass
there their their Community separated
went to the hills they have like a
gorilla God as opposed to the panther
guy yes no the right near us uh about
two and a half hour drive from our
studio there's a pet store called the
stop yes I yes because I've about two
and a half hours from where we are no
wait no there's one there's something
about two and a half hours oh yes start
yeah is that the stock like the Cat
Goddess oh okay okay sorry I just
thought I'd entertain you think it's the
owner my character is the interjector
okay thank you Andrew Jackson well now
I've got a fun fact okay stuff now I I
forget the character's name uh but
um
the actor uh uh from no uh uh Daniel
thank you so sorry my hands are so cold
do you feel this I do feel your cold
hands uh it's from the shame of knocking
over the water I'm not sure
uh he said like I'm not in this movie my
character's not in this movie We're not
gonna see them at all uh and it was very
kind of weird in interviews about it
obviously has not been shown any promo
footage they haven't been showing his
character at all is that like a huge
mystery I thought he outright said he
wasn't in it I know okay fair enough
yeah yeah uh Tobey Maguire said he
outright was not in Spider-Man Andrew
Garfield said he wasn't all right so
we're saying that lives exist in this
universe lies conception
give us your eggs
uh I think I he could show up it could
be like a surprise that would be great
like he was surprised Daniel is a huge
actor right like I just said actors like
you got some inside information no you
guys were talking about John Hamm I
looked it up yesterday keep going oh
okay oh be careful how you Google that
uh no David yeah big name actor if they
were to put somebody you know if they
were gonna put a male character in into
the Black Panther suit like that would
be a fitting now his Arc in the first
movie was interesting because he kind of
was turncoat there he was on
killmonger's side right like kind of
came around at the very end but I don't
think I don't think so I don't think so
I don't think it's character but I do
like and I like the where embaku stands
because he I don't think he would also
that's just me I don't think his that
because it's not what he stands for so
it would be and I don't I still I think
Angela Bassett would hand it down to
someone else because I think Angela bass
is kind of like I'm the one having to
oversee this entire country right now
because my son is gone
we got a word a fight everyone gets a
suit yeah I mean well documented great
Angela Bassett looks for age maybe do we
know that the heart-shaped herb isn't
getting like reduced down to a serum
that she's applying as a night mask
to my brow life
I I do I think if it is in Baku it might
be interesting if he puts on the soup
but he's like I'm not wearing the helmet
I don't do the whole pant this thing
he's got his face out or maybe he's got
his own helmet oh like the gorilla mask
that'd be dope I don't like that now in
that same uh trailer where we see the
two masks jury tells me more that like
he can come and find out well come and
find out yes we again these are trailers
we don't know who they're saying it to
yeah it's played back in like uh there's
Neymar saying is wakanda an enemy or an
ally and then we see a clip I'm sure
he's saying he can come and find out
I'll be honest I watched that trailer
like four or five times and I had big
Jesse Eisenberg in the Batman Superman
trailer like I could not understand what
Neymar was saying at the beginning of it
I thought it was like wakanda is wakanda
available because remember when he says
the with Jesse Eisenberg goes the myth
about power is that it's Innocent but
it's like you know what the myth about
power is this
and that was in the trailer I had that
same Vibe today and it really took me
about 25 minutes I'm glad I finally
identified it with you I love telling
that story The interjector always we
gotta get it we gotta get closed
captioning uh turned on for Tommy's uh
top rope
but velveet is from the censorship or
whatever yeah right right to censors I'm
from the right to censor uh yeah we
don't know who she if she is saying it
to Neymar who knows but it does seem
like if she's threatening him and he's
like okay well I will come and find out
yeah with a lot of water now we've yet
to see any direct again we've mentioned
this a couple times we've seen uh Namor
fight glass we've seen him jump on a
beach and like break somebody's spear
over his shoulder we've yet to see him
directly attack any of the wakandan
characters we know right so I'm still uh
specious of that him punching the window
I know they show in the trailer but like
his reflection in the window and they're
not really responding to it I think it's
a fake out it could be a nightmare
digital thing or it could be a nightmare
sequence yeah right maybe that's it's a
ramonda uh having bad dreams about
somebody coming to ruin her kingdom or
something if it turns out the whole
flood is a nightmare that's gonna be it
won't be that but speaking of nightmares
I was in Pavilions for three and a half
hours yesterday staring at the meat
section oh okay you know I'm used to
people staring at my meat section all
right I I I I I own a supermarket I own
a small Deli anyway
two three four five we want to thank
butcherbox for sponsoring the break room
today I sipped for protein everyone
knows it I'm not denying it in fact I'm
done pretending it's not an issue for me
my problem is I don't know how to get
the sweet sweet meats that I need in
quality Cuts thanks to butcherbox I no
longer have to stand in front of the
meat section at the supermarket like a
cringy boomer okay with butcher box I
get peace of mind when it comes to
buying meat butcherbox takes the
guesswork out of finding high quality
Meat and seafood you can trust 100
grass-fed beef heard of it free-range
organic chicken heard about that around
town pork raise crate free pork and
crates lates you're out and wild caught
seafood and I'm talking Seafood on a
48-hour Bender been to the Sea Under the
Sea casino cheating on their bass wives
it's humanely raised no antibiotics no
added hormones get just what you want
delivered right to your doorstep free
shipping for the continental U.S except
for New Jersey including New Jersey no
surprise fees cheers from variety of box
plan options from curated to customize
you want a whole box full of top round
sirloin I don't know if they can do that
but I'm guessing they can they're
butcher box you want a box full of bacon
wouldn't recommend it curly ate bacon
for every meal you can't do that that's
a quote from City Slickers 1990. watch
it Boomers I mean you shouldn't eat it
because the Second City Slickers is the
search for Curly's gold because he died
Second City Slickers is also a review
they did in Chicago in in 1995. that's
right Second City Slicker Curly's
brother named Duke is introduced in the
cinema in the city slicker Cinematic
Universe say that 10 times fast anyway
get whatever you want from the butcher
box they'll customize it for you and
it's going to be good quality it might
never any Quest eat better and save
money but your box is my new teammate
and like Devin Singletary they hand the
ball out to me as I dive over the goal
line touchdown Buffalo speaking of
Buffalo they got grass-fed buffalo on
that the main course for Thanksgiving
dinner could sometimes be a main source
of stress not anymore butcher boxes
offering listeners free turkey with
their first order sign up today at burnt
turkey so what do you take to the beach
look it up Google Family Feud British
[ __ ] sign up for
measurebox.com break room and use code
break room you got to use the code to
get 110 to 14 pound turkey for free in
your bowling box 10 pounds if you're one
of those guys that bowls with a curve 14
pounds if you're one of those Fred
Flintstones Smasher rules straight down
the end why is it coming in a bowling
ball they come in bowling ball weights
10 to 14 pounds you ever been bowling
probably not you're not much of an
athlete are you yeah I'm more of a 10
pin don't be chewy go to butcherbox.com
break room and use code break room to
claim this deal or else your cream wow
cheese
and by the way thanks to Pluto TV for
sponsoring the break room all week long
and our house of dragon finale breakdown
Pluto tv offers hundreds of free live
channels and thousands of free on-demand
movies thank you interrupter those were
great Ed Reads thank you it was a great
Interruption um real quick we got some
other headlines maybe some things you
might have missed yesterday we kind of
had to throw the whole show out the
window because we wanted to talk about
the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special and finally did we come to a
conclusion is Santa Claus real uh in in
our world or in the MCU it's real right
here
Santa Claus has came in in Marble six
one six there we go he's will probably
be revealed in the MCU as an Omega Level
yes sorry someone in the Chad GSU Eagle
just super chatted Jess is giving me
president Camacho vibes from idiocracy
and I should have done that why didn't I
do it
WWE WCW canon in here right um so a
couple of the uh news items we didn't
get to get to yesterday that we still
wanted to talk about is um of course
back-to-back days for new Marvel
trailers that's never happened no no and
I think first trailer especially by
hackers yeah oh you think that is true
especially the holiday special trailer
kind of leaked a little early and then
Marvel waited for a little minute no
it's also exactly one month out from
when it's going to come out and that's
when we got a werewolf By Night trailer
was one month out so it does seem like I
think if it gets spilled and you have
the means to just release it I think
that's honestly the best route to go and
it is exactly a month so I think it was
meant to come out today it's just
someone did it and then judge uh James
Gunn was like I'm just gonna here you go
how appropriate you said spilled instead
of leak okay okay
it didn't need to happen
it was a preventable mistake via his uh
Instagram Henry Cavill uh a noted star
of The Man from Uncle uh other films
oh oh Army Hammer do you know where the
Man from Uncle is uh canonically in the
TV show where he's from where Rochester
New York oh nice Rochester show your
pride okay with w-o-k-r okay okay
he teased on his Instagram uh more Man
of Steel coming obviously he showed up
it's it's now commonology you should
have been Black Adam The Rock's got his
back the rock yes well Rock Bottom
anyone at DC films who says no oh my God
and now James gun is too afraid James
James Gunn is a small man I'm sorry uh
he's he's not he's not a beefy or a a
hefty or a muscular man so he's
definitely gonna do whatever Dwayne
Johnson you know what though he's sober
and Dwayne loves that tequila so he
catches him unawares um
I'm just saying okay Dwayne drinks a
bottle of Mana maybe James Gunn puts it
on you it's our only chance it's our
only chance to overtake the rock uh but
he said drunk he said on his Instagram a
very small taste of what's to come my
friends the dawn of Hope renewed thank
you for your patience it will be
rewarded cryptic but what do you think
are we getting more Superman maybe we're
getting more men from Uncle I think I
well I don't know if the other star of
Man from Uncle is available right now
he's they're quite an appetite amount
from what I hear by the way this sock
will be available on the new rockstars
merch store uh just this one song it's
very loose okay it's not stiff like
being speculated in the chat this sock
is is we demanded Tommy buy a brand new
socket I I said I had tons of socks at
home to bring in and they said please no
and I said what about towels and they
said even ones so fresh sock will be
available on uh Cree Bay
also uh FYI uh we did discover recently
when of our episodes got kind of
demonetized because we cussed too early
in it and we've we've decided that like
at least in the first half of the
episodes we're going to try to keep them
relatively clean now the back hat [ __ ]
it
hey it's past 3 30. I say anything goes
you [ __ ]
um okay coming from uh Disney's official
production briefing for black panther
what kind of forever producer Nate Moore
uh who's often one of the he's like a
top three guy at Marvel right uh up
there I just love I know it can't be
helped that a main character in Black
Panther is Neymar and a main producer in
Black Panther is Nate Moore it makes me
think it's a marketing stunt Neymar Nate
more I get it I get it people have names
but come on it's fun it's fun it is fun
it's fun you say it fast the
interjector's all he's just lifting the
show
wow uh he teased some phase five
Connections In wakanda Forever he said I
think audiences can expect this movie to
celebrate both the legacy of the
character of t'challa and that of
wakanda as it continues to move forward
it's going to introduce new characters
that you've never seen before and be the
building blocks for the next phase of
the MCU so it's interesting I mean we
have to assume the one new two new
character as we know we're getting are
Neymar and uh Anika right right and oh
and weary Williams yeah great point and
so we know where Riri Williams is
showing up in Iron Heart where do you
think could be the next place we see
Neymar
after wakanda uh could we I mean I know
it would be a rare immediate movie to TV
jump but secret Invasion perhaps oh why
not a little help Invasion depending it
I think we're I mean it's gonna depend
on all these Secret Wars secret Invasion
would be fun if they uh scroll saw him
and then change to be him with his
powers and it's just like flying around
a super strong I love flying around like
I gotta make the the wings on my legs uh
I I it will also depend on how we end
this film if Neymar is seen as like a
villain or yes more on the heroics at
the end because you have films coming up
like Captain America New World Order is
kind of like all over the place yeah
with like it's gonna have the leader in
it and like Thunderball Ross and all
this stuff and it's just like I don't
know what that movie's gonna be about
and if there's a major event in this
film that reshapes the landscape
literally of a country that might even
change the hierarchy of power it could
adjust the hierarchy of power in the MCU
it's possible but that lends itself to
like a new world order like things have
changed and I would also think like
Fantastic Four yeah that's phase six
yeah right not phase five but obviously
through the comics Neymar and the
Fantastic Four have a lot of doings uh
let's see storm has some definite doings
um but in other news in The Hollywood
Reporter Florence Pugh uh supposedly
said to start in a new did I say it
anyway yeah no yeah we were laughing at
Tommy's credit yeah which I love this
movie
have you seen it I generally I love it
and inappropriate for today
um she's really cool they're not all
jokes guys sometimes they're legit
credits okay uh but virtually she's set
to starting a new mystery Marvel movie
now we know she's gonna be in the
Thunderbolts right like she's in the
front of the poster that's been
announced but another a mystery every
Marvel movie and and star is interesting
usage that's not just a cameo well they
say in her Payday for the two movies is
is uh uh what do they call it not eight
fingers not seven figures Oh Daddy she's
getting over 10 mil to do two movies
okay that's star power but we haven't
had movie salaries like that in a while
though gone are the days of the Jim
Carrey 24 million dollar movie so for an
actor specifically a female actor that's
a huge amount of money and a good sign
things are trending up and the Cinematic
space I just need like two hundred
dollars yeah
um but yeah can I hear one of your socks
uh what do we think again we're talking
about we were just saying we're Neymar
might show up next where where else is
is Elena gonna pop in I'd be I I well
The Thundermans well is she yeah she's
in Thunder and thunder but I think
people were just were saying maybe one
of the Avengers movies yeah I think that
was the main speculation in the in the
comment section under that article was
uh they they believe uh can't guidance
well and if iron Wars is um armor Wars
is pivoting to a film right it could be
a spot for her too yeah if she's
sticking with the Val in the team and is
going to be involved in like government
operations you know I think there's
going to be a lot of connection between
New World Order and Thunderbolts yeah
but those both are very stacked films
already in terms of like who's in there
ensembles yeah if it's something weird
like Fantastic Four or you Deadpool I
don't know like
Deadpool oh that would be fun her
comedic line deliveries in the Black
Widow film were so great like that'd be
a good pairing yeah yeah I think
Deadpool would just not make fun of her
but like holy crap yeah if they're not
gonna bring back Deadpool's fun NASA
right that was his girlfriend's name
if they're looking for a new love
interest you want to be Elena it could
be Elena what are you anything you love
interest but just like uh like Domino
was in the last film right just kind of
like a fighting partner Domino men and
women can't be friends exactly you see
what he stands for only relationship
Brandon wrote both of those friends with
benefit movies that came out at the same
time the Mila Kunis and Justin
Timberlake won in the Natalie Portman I
started at his friends
will you marry me
oh my God it's a snake
Damien Zach is not having it also no I
love it we just gotta uh we gotta can
you show me
um in The Hollywood Reporter uh also
this news is fascinating now this is
very industry news it doesn't tell us
anything about what the content is going
to be but there was this secret writer's
room that was put together for Star Wars
right like uh to flesh out the the
feature film taking place uh the next
movie right in the lineup right moving
forward this writing room was put
together supposedly
um Damon Lindelof was kind of at the
head of it this guy Justin Britt Gibson
who's written for some big uh tv as well
um and uh Miss Marvel director charmeen
obeyed chenoy uh and it was kind of like
it was all
um television writers YES station the
head writer station was involved yeah
and they got together after celebration
right like it wasn't even thought of
before then I think I think like the
impetus was they all some people had a
conversation at the celebration yeah
perhaps burned by seeing a young Eric
Boss and myself in the in the crowd
they're like do it for those kids do it
for the kids
these Fresh Face young men
um but supposedly
it was It was decided they liked it yeah
Out of This is Gonna Come not only the
next film but maybe like the next
Trilogy the next sequence of films uh
but interesting that like Star Wars has
been putting out TV yeah right but they
didn't put this writer's room together
for future TV projects yeah it was for
their film and did they did they say if
it's gonna like relate to anything is
this like a continuation of a story are
they gonna try and it's supposed to be
fresh all over it's supposedly gonna be
after the Skywalker Saga yes so like
presumably brand new characters well
they went out of their way to
specifically in the release to say that
it is not a direct sequel to The
Skywalker and Saga but it may involve
characters that we were introduced to in
the uh 2010s Star Wars okay which I
guess would put in Play If I have one in
Solo also oh yeah if I go to this film
and at any point the title card comes up
and it says Tatooine I am going to burn
the movie theater but we need to go back
to tattoo no they have we're done
the sand is full of lightsabers it's
dangerous that's true
I beg you I just feel like it's
important and we should go back I think
they need to make a Hoth move and it
should be a ski resort movie where
there's an old man threatening to shut
down the resort
a lot of good cider scenes
some meat some mulled wine that'd be
great
um and then this is just a really funny
thing the Ant-Man Twitter account
released an adorable ant-sized version
of the trailer is it really small yes I
think do we have the oh wait no we don't
have that asset but we do have the
poster they also released this poster
oh that is still antsized fascinating
though that they that it's all about the
Cayman Kang in this one
and quantumania is huge and the other I
mean I think they're basically trying to
tell you this is a Kang film this is
Kang I mean it's certainly a Quantum
film right yeah the Ant-Man and the West
part is pretty small John the major is
huge I also love like this is definitely
the scarred up the face scars King right
the classic kind of comment variation on
it I love that you've heard of the
Bangbus jump on the cane bus
and I'm always on that okay choo choo
train let me show you how to do that
thing I put a couple extra words in
there it's time for mandatory
the segment that goes 12 rounds so we
play the graphic into the ground hit
that graphic again that segment the
segment that goes off the top rope and
you never say no to hitting the graphic
again playing again the segment that
comes in for a hot tag so we play the
graphic when things start to lag hit the
graphic again oh my God the segment
that's always the number one Contender
so we play the graphic for real not
Pretender hit it again stop him someone
stop this man yes now we are all dressed
as wrestlers IU was dressed as Mankind
and I had a horrible Charlie horse down
the entire left side of my body I
briefly blacked out there was a bright
bright white light I climbed into the
light I swear a man with a giant beard
said I am hip-hop producer Rick Rubin I
cannot help you please stop coming into
my house wow somebody call his doctor Dr
Shabazz no doctor my lawyer is Shabazz
he's a Juris doctor okay they're still
considered doctors did you know in
Europe if you get a law degree you
referred to as Doctor wow wait a lawyer
like is a doctor because you're because
you're technically a Juris doctor so
they they call anyone with a master's
degree I think doctor in Italy get both
you can be an mdj dude get your man oh
MGMT
Mt empty on vacation this week we miss
you Mt we love you I know you're
watching the break room or you watch
every minute anyway we are cutting
promos on the MCU we got two not one but
two trailers and a couple bonus Clips uh
we got the uh trailers for Ant-Man and
the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special so we're all dressed like
wrestlers we're gonna cut some promos on
the MCU today specifically people from
those categories anybody want to go
first well real quick before we start
that I just want to say we have hit our
Super Chat threshold so we will at the
end of this be cutting promos on you the
trash bags you fool but I like them all
so much
Brandon Savage do you want to go first
maybe I can go I can't make fun get them
a microphone I could go first
give me a [ __ ] mic but don't give up
don't give him the title but don't give
him the title I'm not good Scott Center
okay uh I'm going big on mine I'm gonna
I'm going biking you need to come clean
about what's going on with armor Wars
stop jerking my chain okay it's the only
property I'm interested nobody cares
about Fantastic Four nobody cares about
the X-Man nobody cares about Deadpool
give me armor Wars I don't care if it's
a limited series a movie a special
presentation a series of still images
that I gotta crank through on a
Nickelodeon at a local soda pop shop
Frankie you me inside the lucasfilm
volume this Sunday at slamma Jamma mama
in a no holds but I quit loser leaves
down match you will give me armor Awards
or I'll send you straight to hell to say
hello to your mama because in Hell the
cream is always right whoa whoa
wow
I can go next get the butts and seats I
love yours I love you that was excellent
right
listen here brother where's my camera
listen here brother look here Drax I've
been wrestling longer than you and your
wife and child have been alive too soon
didn't think so look here Drax I'm
strong
it's like Drac no Drax don't let the
interject or get to you sorry
look here Drake sorry you couldn't save
your family but I could look at this
back look at how much
I really like a boat and I'm getting the
water and I'm swimming the saw I'll swim
in the short tracks you could never do
that I've been wrestling so long so long
look at these Hulk Maniacs your wife's a
hulkamaniacs Drax whatever Tommy didn't
say I said the opposite of now look here
you're doing great look here
come fight me find me when you come to
Earth and I'll challenge you because
Hulkamania is running wild brother oh oh
Maniacs at the silver door
I lost my mankind mess so I'm gonna cut
my promo in the style of uh Ric Flair oh
very nice take your headphones out take
your headphones out one
jacked group
by God Jack group I'm a limousine riding
high-flying too so have my gun and I'm
gonna take your mother Mama Earth on all
the way up to Space Mountain baby
oh Jack group
what are you on HGH human group hormone
getting all human pecs nobody should
have human pets when they're a tree let
me tell you something I'm gonna take a
bite out of you check your syrup make
some pancakes and die in a group juice
did it I watch inside me crew hang on
let me take that back
I'm gonna climb up inside you group I'm
gonna pour a hole in your trunk and set
up like an owl
I'm gonna be a lumberjack and take an x
on that ass
we're flying up high and we're going
down low but just remember wood burns
but diamonds are forever
not to be the interjector but it did
sound like you were saying Jack Bruce I
thought he was saying I went to high
school with a jack de Groot it was a
Dutch foreign exchange series check it
out
you know Ric Flair famously would strip
his clothes off when he was caught in
the price I already took my clothes off
I can't we can't get demonetized anymore
than we already have enough male nipples
the shirt yes uh department store oh my
God I thought it was mine
whoa oh is that is that somebody's is it
somebody's music right here
oh no I know what it does is that
is it I thought I thought I heard
oh oh my God
I'm sure it's playing
oh
what's up
I've never been on with this person we
specifically said but I did get out of a
Guantanamo videos
oh how's it going piss nuts what's up
I have a bone to pick right now I was
hearing your little promo things yes I
have to admit wrestling is sort of a
human thing uh where I come from we
fight to the death with magic so I don't
know what is your name the quiz Master
then I don't get this well I have one
quiz today one quiz question if you will
and that's what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you
all my Instagram targeted ads are why I
can't get it up or why I don't poop
right I guess that would be problem
number one on Earth are you insulting
our beloved drafts like that that is my
question that was him I said directs
now listen here's what I want from you
freaks okay uh I don't really know who
the [ __ ] you're supposed to be dressed
as this is like a like a hippie Cowboy
Weird Al Yankovic
it's the national holiday of Anna
vanston's birthday hey what did y'all
get her for her birthday oh whatever
sweet treat was in the office I paid for
with out of my own money yeah do you
usually share an office with her so I
think I give her the joy of my
friendship just I don't know if y'all
knew all she wanted was a like and
comment on her latest Instagram
that's a good reminder if you haven't
liked this video yet you better do it
now or I'm gonna unload on you
know don't you just
yeah oh sorry I co-opted your plug for
the better of the show
a little brochure wow uh go to at
goombana
I didn't hear Hermione's name out loud
and I thought her name was her Moon
the Pirates of the Caribbean you never
know which ones yeah yeah quiz Master
you normally come with a quiz are there
questions to be answered today the
question was what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you and where is my apology I'm so sorry
so much is wrong with me please go to
her Instagram go to the quiz go to
Anna's quiz Master go to Anna's
Instagram like it comment on it I'm very
scared right now please don't hurt click
that remote
quiz master I have my limits
time so I get it I get it but wait do
you have covet on your planet or
something similar everyone has we've
always had codes do they call it quiz
Master kovic because you call it human
covet is it quiz Master oh yeah or quiz
Master is your people or is that your
neighbor your your like species yeah
I apologize that's a stupid question
only one quiz master I also took the
Twitter Handle by the way
anyway I have better things to do I've
gotten my apology anyone else want to
apologize for anything no but I think
maybe we should sing happy birthday
that's a good idea
[Applause]
yes happy birthday to Anna thank you for
that Dirge of an American Birthday song
Hey I was trying to sing the black one
okay happy birthday to you that's not
the one happy birthday
oh [ __ ]
um thanks thanks to you losers too
um I know all of your sins I watch you
at night
did we just establish that quiz Master
is omnipotent I well I think either has
the abilities of Santa to tell if we're
not nice this one is always watching wow
oh and there's the FBI again they just
threw a net over oh God finally finally
bring him to Justice
we did we did hit our chat Redemption
you know what I don't need to do a
mandatory fun because I gotta do it on
these oh yes you know it's not mandatory
but will be fun for me ripping these
trash bags
okay yes brother you think I don't see
you house it wrong town you don't want
to talk about wrong town it's whatever
town you live in okay yeah up oh Quentin
Quentin Quinton uh uh uh Taran T no way
I'm gonna chat about you
um
uh oh Tasha Tasha so so uh actually
leave her alone I love her okay she's
she's really nice you can't talk to my
girl Tasha Tasha you get a pass pass uh
Boogie's World more like uh booger world
the MJ two nine nine seven I have to
assume MJ stands for Michael Jordan well
you can call me gambling addiction cause
I'm the only thing that can stop you I'm
gonna make you disappear for two years
go try another career path then come
back once the feds have cooled down so
Christian unpronounceable I just said it
MJ 2997 wants us to do uh some glow
shutouts here's a shout out for glow
Genji Coda can't finish a series
but drop off pretty quickly they get
lost in the weeds
I shouldn't hold on to this microphone
because I'll get in trouble by Zach but
TD Jones more like PP Jones
wow Noah precious Thorn I'm about to do
something precious based on the novel
pushed by Sapphire to you and that's so
I don't want to actually go into the
podcast myself very depressing I'm gonna
throw you in a dumpster your trash bag
uh Aaron's storm more like Aaron class
five loser storm Nina you what is that a
university actually leave Nina alone too
she's my can I can I can I burn one can
I bring it back I needed you but I'm
watching you okay back again with
another one Mr Feeney more like Mr tiny
peony oh
the only van you get in is one driven by
a stranger full of Milky Ways and they
never find you again
oh oh oh what's that Matthew Nunya you
always make my week thank you for going
live five days a week I love when you
all four get together guests are cool
but not as poor as all of you love you
well Matthew Nunya you better take that
little sweet message of yours put it in
an envelope drop it off at the post
office and send it to yourself and when
you open it up take that some [ __ ]
sideways and RAM it up yeah
GSU Eagle 117. you know what an anagram
of Eagle is LG cause you're goop you
swamp goop you swap scum you get scooped
out of a fish tank in front of the trash
with the rest of the chat oh Alex win in
the chat wants us to roast aew don't
have to do that just turn it on and
watch it CM Punk has done that for us
Juan Sanchez uh
about what one
one more roast was clearly more than I
had in me okay
um
thank you all for tuning in to this uh
quasi wrestling themed episode of the
break room Kevin Gunn the pen is
mightier than the sword and I'm gonna
take a piece of paper and cut you a
thousand times oh nice that's my
thousand paper cuts Kevin Gunn more like
Kevin water pistol also the only gun not
getting work at DC oh hey yo okay Pluto
tv offers hundreds of free live channels
and thousands of free on-demand movies
um thank you all so much for watching
we'll be back tomorrow our apologies to
end our apologies
no apologies no we'll see you
in the squared Circle brother
foreign
[Music]